alors je suis en bonne santé ne vous
inquiétez pas d'ailleurs je me plains
pas avec mon corps c'est juste que le
mec qui a imaginé mon corps avait perdu
les plans il est parti en impro je
m'appelle france
oui je suis le créateur du cordes
cyprien pour faire simple j'ai fait
n'importe quoi en terme de pilosité
faciale par exemple mes poils ne savent
pas où s'arrêter ma barbe montrent juste
en haut des joues bientôt sous mes yeux
qui a décidé de sa ya comment va ta
famille je travaille sur un nouveau
modèle beaucoup de travail en ce moment
yahia cercoux tomberait sa famille pour
moi yaovi d all things quoi bon ça fait
pas très viril avoué voilà je m'épile ce
sinon ça fait dégueulasse j'ai pas le
choix mais le pire ce sont mes sourcils
en fait parce que parfois dans les
sketchs d'école je me fais un mono
sourcil mais en vrai c'est ce qui
m'arrive si je m'épile pas à croire que
mes sourcils sont faits pour se réunir
[Musique]
non
on va rester dans le poêle mes cheveux
ont une implantation particulière gelé
quoi mais le matin au réveil quand je
sors de la douche
ils reprennent leur forme originelle
c'est à dire un petit dessus relevés sur
les côtés à tomber tu ressembles à un
wolverine au chanteur m qui t'amuse un
connard où j'ai des problèmes de vue ça
ça tout le monde est au courant mais
bien sûr je ne pouvais pas faire comme
tout le monde non oeil droit
youpi gauche a stigmatisé permettront un
nouveau délire d'ailleurs on voit bien
la différence entre mes deux verres pour
que moi arnheim manager tout mélanger
bohm on va prendre assez de la wii il
sonne l'heure de la même couleur j'ai un
problème de sudation quelqu'un dit j'ai
un problème de sudation que ça veut dire
qu'ils transpirent comme un gros porc je
suis obligé d'utiliser un déo spécial
trouvable en pharmacie parce que depuis
que je suis ado je transpire d'élite
surtout des aisselles même si fait au
moyen chaud même s'il fait tiennent même
s'il fait froid afin que je sors dehors
quelques secondes j'ai des auréoles
sympa
[Musique]
une bonne journée qui commence à manger
un petit peu abusé avec mon corps aussi
il faut savoir que quand je suis arrivé
sur paris à 18 ans j'ai pris cinq kilos
en quelques semaines puis j'ai pris cinq
kilos en plus depuis un pour être c'est
plus correct c'est parce que j'étais
stressé en fait et mon métabolisme a
réagi ah non alors fait non je sais pas
ce que je mangeais comme un gros porc
c'est vrai
et c'est là que mon corps intervient
puisqu'il a décidé de ne pas grossir
comme tout le monde je fais pas foumban
tirs là on a foiré
je pourrais avoir du ventre des joues
mais non quand je grossis le haut du
corps ne bouge pas je prend uniquement
des fesses des cuisses et des poignées
d'amour
oui exactement comme une femme voilà
arabia grosser ah ouais on a mis toute
la grèce dans les cuisses les poignées
d'amour ça va être une très belle femme
a well va être super joli avec des
jolies courbes ddc d'un c'est un homme
depuis depuis le début c'est un peu vous
nous dites ça maintenant vous ça fait 26
ans et une femme mais de la grèce dans
ses cuisses [ __ ] vrai débat communiqué
je suis comme ça hein j'ai des goûts
revanche j'ai des grosses cuisses vous
voyez les mannequins avec les hanches
larges comme ça et donc vont rentrer un
dans chaque jambe
voilà c'est la vie il ya beaucoup
d'hommes qui ont peur dans la rue de
mater un cul et de s'apercevoir qu'en
fait c'est un autre homme
et ben moi ma peur en plus de ça c'est
que le mec à qui on mettre le cul ce
soit moi
voilà ma vie et puis j'ai décidé de me
reprendre en main pour perdre les kilos
en trop surtout après cet été après
avoir vu une photo de moi oui ce sont
bien des saints que vous voyez là désolé
aussi j'avais de la grèce en plus j'en
ai miro je me suis donc mis au régime
pop up
je suis désolé la vidéo ce régime c'est
moi c'est déjà fait j'ai perdu 26 kg à
la carte mais combien de puits pas du
tout des salomon régime est plutôt
simple je ne mange plus de pain et je
mange léger le soir c'est tout et
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
un régime c'est ainsi compliqué jour 1
narbonne cette soupe en fait jour sait
déjà que deux bases
j'ai faim tout le temps alors là je ne
pense qu'à ça je veux du gras et en vo
présent merci beaucoup
je crois aussi un peu de persil mana
mais la grande révolution dans ma vie
c'est que je fais du sport c'est
vraiment tout nouveau pour moi parce que
je n'ai jamais été ce parti j'étais
toujours le dernier choisi dans les
équipes en sport avec jeux j'hésite
j'hésite
on va prendre je suis le dernier tu n'as
pas le choix on va faire un plouf plouf
en tant que non sportifs jeux là vous
c'est dur pour moi de courir et j'en ai
parlé avec des gens qui font du running
régulièrement ils m'ont tous sortis sans
aucune exception la course
clairement c'est comme une drogue tudor
la raison la raison la course
c'est exactement comme une drogue on est
d'accord on sait comme toi aussi tu pars
excuse moi je vous entends parler parce
que la course c'est comme une drogue
d'accord c'est comme une drogue
c'est comme une drogue usées moi
j'habite en dessous en fait je vous
entends par la course et c'est comme une
drogue la course tu m'entends c'est
marrant parce que je ne savais pas que
la drogue ça faisait ça oh [ __ ] les
crampes à l'écran [ __ ] ça nique à
j'arrête j'arrête la drogue
bref j'ai perdu 7 kilos en un mois et
demi donc j'y crois qu'on reprenne
petite vidéo dans quelques mois pour
savoir où on est si j'ai pas compris en
tout cas as-tu mais vous dans votre
corps qui soit pis le nom pilou toutes
les formes de toutes les couleurs
transpirant non comme vous vous les
assumez vous c'est important voilà c'est
tout pour mon corps arnheim je n'ai pas
terminé encore une petite surprise
il va commencer à perdre ses cheveux
quoi
mais non
[Musique]